-Donald Trump kicked off
his 2024 presidential bid
with a series of campaign
stops in key primary states
and attacks on his main rival,
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis.
And yet, even as Trump forges
ahead with a 2024 bid
that no one except his hardcore
fans seems to want,
everyone who actually
has the power to stop him,
whether it's his
fellow Republicans
or federal prosecutors,
has refused to take action,
hoping he'll magically go away,
just like they did in 2016.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Republican Party is facing
a reckoning right now
over its future after
its disastrous performances
in three straight
national elections,
which have left the party
weak, fractured and rudderless.
And who better to help
with that reckoning
than MyPillow CEO
Mike Lindell.
The Republican
National Committee
pledged to work
with Lindell
and keep him involved
in the party's leadership
after Lindell ran to become
the chair of the RNC.
Sadly, Lindell lost
that election on Friday
to current chair Ronna McDaniel.
Or so they say.
And I hope I don't sound
too much like Mike Lindell
when I say this,
but I think he
only lost because China,
Hugo Chavez,
the CIA and Dominion teamed up
to steal the election from him!
And also she may be ahead now,
but sometimes slow
and steady wins the race!
Like in that story,
the tortoise and the hare!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think -- I think in the end,
I did sound a little like him.
Anyway, Lindell lost,
but he made it clear
that he's still expected
to be closely involved
with the GOP leadership
after a poll
of Republican voters
showed he was their favorite
to take over the RNC.
-We need to hold
the RNC accountable.
They did say,
"I will work with Mike Lindell.
I can't wait to work
with Mike Lindell."
And Ronna said she would work,
she would do a grassroots tour
But she also said,
I'm looking forward
to working with Mike Lindell.
Steve, what do you work --
what do you think I've been
working on for two years?
So this is a wake up
call to them.
You better wake up.
I better get that phone call.
-Okay, word of advice, Mike.
You need to be a little quieter
or else you're not going to hear
when that phone rings.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, just watch
all these missed calls.
-Let's look into it.
[ Telephone ringing ]
What are they hiding, Steve?
What are they hiding?
They're running out of track...
[ Telephone ringing ]
...where they're not going to be
able to keep going these dumps
or it's going to be too obvious.
Open it up
and look good in there.
They're all the computers.
[ Telephone ringing ]
They go horizontal, everybody.
-And just to show that she was
serious about keeping Lindell
involved at the highest levels
of the GOP,
McDaniel made a show of
inviting him on stage,
along with one other
fellow candidate,
former Trump campaign lawyer
Harmeet Dhillon
after McDaniel won,
even calling Lindell
a leader in the GOP.
-Thank you.
We got to --
we got to get Mike
and Harmeet up here.
Mike and Harmeet,
can you please come up?
Thank you
for the race you ran,
for the leaders
you are in our party.
We are so grateful for you.
We need all of us.
We heard you, grassroots.
We know. We heard Harmeet.
We heard Mike Lindell.
But with us united
and all of us going together,
the Democrats
are going to hear us in 2024
when we take back the
White House and the Senate.
-I mean, that's a dream team
right there.
Ronna McDaniel,
who oversaw three straight
blowout losses in '18, '20
and '22,
Harmeet Dhillon, legal advisor
for Donald Trump's 2020 campaign
and a pillow salesman famous
for getting his phone seized
by the FBI at a Hardee's
drive-through, a real thing.
A real thing that happened.
This is a very real headline.
In fact, the feds
disguise themselves
as the drive-through menu
[ Laughter ]
It was so weird for everyone who
drove through before Lindell.
"Hey, are you dude dressed up
like a sign?"
"Keep driving."
[ Laughter ]
No one expects to lose a phone
at a drive-through.
There's no video of it,
but we do have audio
of Lindell's order
after the seizure.
[ Laughter ]
Should I tell them?
That was me, you guys.
[ Laughter ]
I did both voices.
Now, in case you forgot
the specifics of this story,
Lindell had his phone seized
as part of an FBI investigation
into a Republican county clerk
in Colorado
who tampered
with voting equipment
to investigate
nonexistent voter fraud.
And despite that,
Trump is still his friend,
and the chair
of the Republican Party
says he should be involved
in the party's leadership.
I honestly can't think of any
Democratic equivalent to this.
Like, imagine if Joe Biden
brought a guy on stage
who sells compression socks
and claims the moon is actually
just a projection
to distract people.
"Alright, everybody,
I'd like to introduce
MySock CEO, Rick Kordell.
Great guy, great patriot
who makes great socks
and he says the moon isn't
real."
[ Laughter ]
"But we got room
for a lot of ideas
inside the Democratic Party.
What's that? What's that, Rick?
Now, okay.
He's telling me Google Maps
is an invention
of lizard people,
and these lizard people
are using it
to coordinate an attack.
That's great stuff, Rick.
That's why I don't use maps.
I just wander around until
someone tells me where to go."
[ Laughter ]
So that's the position
the GOP finds itself in.
They all want to pretend
that Trump and his gang
and weirdos are done,
but they also don't think
they have a future without them.
For example, on the one hand,
they keep insisting
over and over that
Trump is the past
and that he can't win
a general election.
-Donald Trump kept saying,
we're going to be
winning so much,
we'll get tired of winning.
I'm tired of losing.
I mean, it's all he's done.
-Look, I don't think he can
win in '20 --
in November of '24.
-Trump is the past.
He's fading fast.
He's a proven loser.
He cost us the House at '18.
He cost us
the White House in '20.
He cost us the Senate
again and again.
And I think we all know that,
and I think we're moving
past Trump.
-Does Trump win?
I hope so.
I love the guy.
And a week ago,
I would have said slam dunk.
But after how last night
shook out, I don't know now.
-I've said over and over again
that he can't
win a general election.
And that's not speculation.
That's based upon the polling
that I was privy
to pre the 2020 election
and what we saw actually happen
in the 2020 election.
And it's only gotten worse
since then.
Then add to it
what you saw happen in 2022,
and I think Republicans
are recognizing that.
-Sure, Chris Christie,
you maybe said it over and over,
but that was after you said over
and over he should be president
and he should be reelected.
You were one of the first
elected Republicans
to support him in 2016.
You helped him prep
for his debates in 2020.
You even stood behind him
at press conferences in 2016
like a presenter
at the Golden Globes
who had just handed him
an award
and forgot to get out
of the shot.
[ Whispering ] "Chris, get off
stage!
[ Laughter ]
Chris!
Get off...
Get off stage!"
[ Normal voice] In fact, the
parallels between how the GOP
is treating Trump now
and how they treated him
in 2016 are pretty alarming.
You might remember the exact
same thing happening back then.
Republicans kept insisting
there was no way
Trump could get enough support
to win the primary,
that he had a hard ceiling
that he would lose
once the party
coalesced around an alternative
and that he would definitely get
crushed in a general election.
-What you're seeing is a sense
that the party is not going
to coalesce around Donald Trump
if he is the nominee.
-If the Republican Party
becomes the party of David Duke,
Donald Trump, I'm out.
-Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell
told GOP colleagues they can
drop Trump "like a hot rock."
-He's got a high floor
and a low ceiling,
in my opinion.
I mean, Donald Trump
has proven himself
capable of getting 25% to 30%.
-Donald has a hard ceiling
of 35% to 40%.
-There's a ceiling
beyond which he cannot go,
and that ceiling
would not be 50%.
-50% ceiling sounds like
a feature that real estate mogul
Donald Trump would try to sell
when you complain
about half the roof missing.
"You're complaining.
You're complaining
about the rain
pouring into your apartment.
But let me tell you,
when it's sunny out,
you're going to be thanking me
for this 50% deal.
Everybody loves a 50% ceiling."
Remember when everyone thought
Trump had a ceiling,
even though he literally
started his campaign
at the top of an escalator?
I mean, look at that guy.
It's really hard to believe now
he was headed to the most
powerful office in the world.
He looks like he's headed
to Claire's
to get his ears pierced.
[ Laughter ]
"You guys go ahead.
I'll meet you at chess, gang."
This is what keeps happening
with Trump.
Republicans Just assume he's
done, that someone else
will take him down,
but no one actually does it.
And it's happening
all over again right now
as Trump kicks off
his 2024 campaign.
In a new article about the GOP's
refusal to take on
Trump directly,
one GOP consultant said...
Another Republican,
who ran Marco Rubio's
2016 campaign said...
It doesn't even have to be
that heavy of a brick.
If Donald Trump
were actually in the water,
I'm pretty sure all I would take
is to throw him a pebble
to sink him.
You could throw him a pillow
even, though not a MyPillow.
That thing is probably heavier.
That's like 50 bricks.
You try to sleep on one of
those, you immediately...
-Wake up!
[ Laughter ]
-And it's not just...
I mean, it should be
an alarm on your phone.
I'm just saying.
Just put it on Lindell
in the morning.
You're gonna wake up.
It's not just Republicans.
Even prosecutors are punting
when it comes to Trump.
A new book has revealed
that days before Trump...
...because Trump's
other scandals...
They're all just waiting
for someone else to do it.
It's like when you're at
a family party and Aunt Janet
has one too many gin and tonics
and everyone knows
and is just hoping
someone else will intervene
and tell her
to put the glass down,
but then no one does it
and she ends up telling
the entire family
about the exact time
and location
your cousin was conceived.
"Your Uncle Stu
wasn't exactly a romantic.
We were at a Motel 6
in Niagara Falls,
but they didn't have any rooms,
so we just went back
to the station wagon.
And nine months later, boom!
Happy birthday, Kayleigh."
[ Laughter ]
"Then I -- did I say a thing."
So that's how we got to
where we are now with Trump,
a guy who fomented a coup
to overthrow American democracy,
making official campaign stops
in early primary states.
Even his prosecutors
and his fellow Republicans
just sit on their hands waiting
for someone else to stop him.
The parallels with 2016
are so eerie,
we're even getting Trump doing
the same silly sound effects
he did
during his first campaign,
like when he told this
random story in New Hampshire
that I couldn't even follow him
about being on Air Force One.
-So, we're landing.
We're getting 700.
I say, "So, Captain."
I say, sure, it's fine.
And so 600, 500, 400.
Then he goes 300.
So now we're 300 feet over,
which is nothing.
And, "Captain,
we're okay, right?"
"Yes. Yes, sir."
And then all of a sudden,
200, 100.
I just close my eyes.
Bing, bing, boom.
Landed it perfect.
-Wait, that.
[ Laughter ]
That sounds so familiar.
Oh, God, no.
No, it can't be happening again.
-Bing, bing, bong, bong,
bing, bing, bing, bing.
-Don't you see what's
happening?!
Donald Trump has created
a time loop.
We're all being
sucked back into.
[ Echoing ] The year 2016.
[ Thunder crashes ]
[ Evil laughter ]
-Bing, bing, bong, bong,
bing, bing, bing, bing.
[ Laughter ]
-2016.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They better not make me wear
a [bleep] suit again.
[ Laughter ]
Look at that.
Look at that beautiful baby boy.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is just up there as if he
never once incited a coup
or oversaw one of the most
disastrous,
chaotic presidencies
in American history.
He's even freely taking shots
at his main rival, Ron DeSantis.
No one in the GOP seems to care.
In fact, Trump spent all weekend
going after DeSantis,
calling him disloyal if he runs
while he was
on his campaign plane
flying from one stop
to the next.
-So, Ron would have not be
governor
if it wasn't for me,
and that's okay.
And number one, he wouldn't have
gotten the nomination.
And number two,
he wouldn't have beat
his Democratic opponent.
So then when I hear
he might run, you know,
I consider that very disloyal.
But it's not about loyalty,
but to me it is.
It's always about loyalty,
but for a lot of people.
-Okay, first of all,
so psyched we're back to Trump
doing press conferences
in places
where we can barely hear him.
You need to speak up, dude.
I can't believe I'm saying this,
but take a cue
from Mike Lindell.
Also, do you think
Trump's insults are bad now?
Wait until he sees
that picture
of DeSantis in his fancy
white boots.
It's a real picture.
Can you imagine what Trump
is going to say once he sees
that picture of the DeSantis?
"You know, it's not fair.
Many people are sitting
around stole
those fancy little boots from
the Dallas Cowboys cheerleaders.
And he should give them back.
It's not nice.
Those poor cheerleaders,
they have nothing to wear now.
They have to cheerlead
in their bare feet, so sad."
[ Laughter ]
At so many turns
there was so many people
who had the power to stop Trump
and make sure we didn't have
to live through this nightmare
all over again.
For one thing,
Republicans could have convicted
him during his impeachment trial
and disqualified him
from office.
Instead, they're just
sitting on their hands,
quietly hoping a magically
disappear strategy
that failed in 2016.
If Republicans don't take
on Trump directly,
he could very well tear through
them like it did in 2016.
And if he does,
it'll sound like this.
-Bing, bing, bong, bong,
bing, bing, bing.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]